THE ACTUAL SCIENCE OF
EPIDEMIOLOGY ARE ASKING HARD
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE POLICIES.
HERE IS A PHYSICIAN AND
RESEARCHER FROM CALIFORNIA
CALLED DR. DAN ERICKSON.
HE HAD A PARTNER DELIVERED A 50
MINUTE BRIEFING ON THE LATEST
NUMBERS FROM CALIFORNIA.
THE VIDEO THEY MADE HAS BEEN
VIEWED MILLIONS OF TIMES IN A
FEW DAYS ONLINE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS AFTER LOOKING
CAREFULLY AT THE DATA, THESE TWO
RESEARCHERS HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD END ITS
SHELTER-IN-PLACE ORDER.
WATCH.
>> WE HAVE SEEN 1,227 DEATHS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH A
POSSIBLE INCIDENT OR PREVALENCE
OF 4.7 MILLION.
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE A 0.03
CHANCE OF DYING FROM COVID-19
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
0.03 CHANCE OF DYING FROM COVID
DOES THAT NECESSITATE SHELTERING
IN PLACE?
DOES THAT NECESSITATE SHUTTING
DOWN MEDICAL SYSTEMS?
DOES THAT NECESSITATE PEOPLE
BEING OUT OF WORK?
>> Tucker: AND THESE ARE
SERIOUS PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE
THIS FOR A LIVING FOR DECADES.
THEY HAVE AND THEIR HANDS THE
LARGEST CURRENTLY AVAILABLE DATA
SET ON THIS QUESTION.
THE QUESTION THEY ARE ASKING
AFTER ANALYZING ALL OF THOSE
NUMBERS, ARE THE LOCKDOWNS WORTH
IT?
SO WHAT IS THE ANSWER TO THAT?
WHAT IS SO STRIKING IS THAT SO
MANY POLITICIANS, THE ONE
ENFORCING A LOCKDOWN DON’T SEEM
INTERESTED IN ASKING IT.
THEY’RE PULLING FORWARD AS IF
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
ANNOUNCED IT WILL BE EXTENDING
ITS LOCKDOWN UNTIL THE END
OF MAY.
THAT IS FIVE WEEKS FROM NOW.
WHAT IS A SCIENTIFIC
JUSTIFICATION FOR DOING THAT?
THEY DIDN’T TELL US, BECAUSE
THERE IS NONE.
NONE.
YOU MAY REMEMBER WHAT THEY FIRST
TOLD US IN FEBRUARY AND MARCH.
THEY TOLD US WE HAVE TO TAKE
RADICAL STEPS IN ORDER TO
"FLATTEN THE CURVE."
SIX WEEKS LATER WE ARE HAPPY TO
SAY THAT CURVE HAS BEEN A
FLATTENED, BUT IT’S LIKELY NOT
BECAUSE OF THE LOCKDOWN.
THE VIRUS JUST ISN’T NEARLY AS
DEADLY AS WE THOUGHT IT WAS, ALL
OF US, INCLUDING ON THE SHOW.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT WAS, BUT IT
TURNED OUT NOT TO BE.
HOSPITALS NEVER COLLAPSED.
OUTSIDE A TIDY NUMBER OF PLACES,
THEY NEVER CAME CLOSE TO
COLLAPSING.
INSTEAD SOMETHING REMARKABLE
HAPPENED, SOMETHING AMAZING
REALLY WITHOUT PARALLEL TO
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE OPPOSITE HAPPENS.
THANKS TO THE LOCKDOWNS
HOSPITALS HAVE BEGUN TO
COLLAPSE, WHY?
A LACK OF PATIENCE.
POLITICIANS WHO COULDN’T PASS
TENTH GRADE BIOLOGY DECIDED THAT
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS NOT BE
ALLOWED TO TRANSMIT THE VIRUS,
THEY’RE JUST NOT QUALIFIED.
UNLIKE US.
THESE POLITICIANS BANNED
SO-CALLED NONESSENTIAL
PROCEDURES, MANY OF WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL.
THE RESULTS OF THIS POLICY, AND
MANY HOSPITALS, ENTIRE FLOORS.
DOCTORS AND NURSES ARE BEING
FURLOUGHED IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
THIS IS INSANITY, IT WEAKENS OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
ITS EFFECTS WILL LAST FOR MANY
YEARS.
THAT IS ALL FROM THE LOCKDOWN.
SO HOW LONG WILL WE HAVE TO LIVE
WITH THESE LOCKDOWNS?
EARLIER THIS MONTH DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI WHOM WE ARE ACQUIRED BY
LAW TO RESPECT NO MATTER WHAT HE
SAYS, SUGGESTED THAT WE MAY
NEVER BE ALLOWED TO RESUME
NORMAL LIFE.
>> IT BACK TO NORMAL MEANS THERE
NEVER WAS A CORONAVIRUS PROBLEM,
I DON’T THINK THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN UNTIL WE DO HAVE THE
SITUATION WHERE YOU CAN
COMPLETELY PROTECT THE
POPULATION.
IF YOU WANT TO GET TO
PRECORONAVIRUS, THAT MIGHT NOT
EVER HAPPEN IN THE SENSE OF, THE
FACT THAT THE THREAT IS THERE.
>> Tucker: WE SHOULD TELL YOU
THAT IS THE SAME DR. FAUCI, AND
KEEP THIS TO YOURSELF BECAUSE AS
NOTED IN THE SUN A LOT TO SHOW
ANY SKEPTICISM, BUT THAT’S THE
SAME DR. FAUCI WHO ANNOUNCED
THAT SHAKING HANDS, THE ANCIENT
CUSTOM OF SHAKING HANDS SHOULD
BE DONE AWAY WITH FOREVER.
AND THEN A WEEK LATER TOLD
SNAPCHAT THAT ACTUALLY IT’S FINE
TO HAVE SEX WITH STRANGERS YOU
MEET ON TENDER PREY THAT WAS HIS
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL ADVICE.
OTHER EXPERTS WARNED THAT
FULL-BLOWN LOCKDOWNS MAY BE
NECESSARY UNTIL A VACCINE OR
TREATMENTS ARE FOUND.
WHAT THEY DIDN’T MENTION IS THAT
SCIENTISTS HAVE NEVER PRODUCED A
SINGLE APPROVED VACCINE OR
ANTIVIRAL DRUG FOR ANY
CORONAVIRUS.
SO THAT COULD BE A WHILE.
THAT THOUGHT SEEMED TO PLEASE
FREQUENT TELEVISION GUEST ZQ
MANUAL.
>> READS ECSTATICALLY, COVID-19
WILL BE HERE FOR THE NEXT 18
MONTHS OR MORE.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
NORMALCY UNTIL WE FIND A VACCINE
OR EFFECTIVE MEDICATIONS.
ALL THAT ECONOMIC PAIN, IS IT
WORTH TRYING TO STOP COVID-19?
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NO CHOICE.
>> Tucker: OH, THE TRUTH IS WE
HAVE NO CHOICE.
HERE’S A HANDY GUIDE FOR YOU IN
CASE YOU WATCH A LOT OF
TELEVISION.
WHEN A POLITICAL OPERATIVE LIKE
EZEKIEL EMANUEL, SOMEONE WITH A
LONG HISTORY OF LYING BEGINS A
SENTENCE WITH THE PHRASE, "THE
TRUTH IS" YOU SHOULD BE ON
GUARD.
WHEN HE ENDS THAT SENTENCE WITH
"YOU WE HAVE NO CHOICE" YOU
SHOULD BE TERRIFIED.
THAT IS WRONG, WE’VE ALWAYS HAD
A CHOICE.
OTHER COUNTRIES MADE DIFFERENT
CHOICES FROM MARS AND A FACT.
THEY’RE NOT WAITING FOR A
VACCINE TO OPEN THEIR SOCIETY.
WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
THERE IS NO PRESIDENT FOR DOING
THAT.
THAT’S A SCIENTIFIC MATTER.
WE SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
MORE THAN A DECADE TRYING TO
FIND VACCINE FOR THE CZAR’S SIRE
STOMACH VIRUS.
DID WE HALT LIFE UNITED STATES
AND RESPONSE?
WE DIDN’T.
YOU MAY NOT EVEN REMEMBER THAT
ANY OF THAT HAPPENED.
FOR STRIKING THING IS THE
SCIENCE HAS NOT CHANGED THAT
MUCH SINCE THEN.